everybody welcome back to this fourth
and final installment of the special
series of austin build we look back at
the props and costumes that we made for
the Mad Max fury road review and so
today we're going to be looking at the
model cars and trucks and stuff that we
built for the review
I have a lot of footage courtesy of rob
was filming on the day of or the days
that we were actually shooting on set
when Doug came to me initially and he
said he wanted it to be practical and he
wanted to shoot model trucks and cars
and stuff and initially he thought that
some of the cars might be CG but at
least he wanted the two main cars to be
models so he had a very specific design
in mind he wanted it to mimic the
roadrunner and coyote from the old
Warner Brothers cartoons but obviously
he didn't want it to be so that you saw
it immediately in it that's what it
looked like he wanted it to be a hint of
it so that when there is the reveal you
kind of get in silhouette what it would
be hello it was kind of a tricky process
I had to find vehicles and cars that I
thought would kind of fit into that form
and then adjust them to fit that
specific design that he was looking for
so this is what I came up with but the
other request to it was specific that
the one truck had to have some kind of
arms or claws that it could reach out
for the other for the roadrunner car
when I got closer to the actual filming
date you might have actually already
been in production it might have already
started filming Doug had decided that he
actually did want all the cars and
trucks to be actual practical models and
just the Michael Bay car would be CGI so
but the devil burner car he was like can
you make a really kick-ass car for devil
boner and like I said I think we were
may have already began filming or I
think we released in well into
production
I had this model or this toy Jeep so it
was just sitting there so when he said I
just I don't have any specific idea I
just needed to look really badass
the devil boner would drive so I took
some of the other spare parts and pieces
of scrap and literally in about a
half-hour put together the devil boner
car Rob did the the paint job and the
paint job is awesome it really sells it
so all of you know it was this initially
just this Jeep and with bits of pieces
of foam and other model cars glued to it
and then all these pieces of scrap
plastic that I cut into jagged shards
and glued on there and stuff and yeah
with Rob's awesome paint job that's how
that one was conceived and built so
that's the one that everybody likes the
most it's usually usually the way it
goes it's usually the the prop that I
spent the least amount of time on that
people seem to gravitate you the most so
I hope you guys enjoy let's take a look
all right so we've got a lot of work did
you for this Mad Max review models for
some of the vehicles we have to build
interiors for some of the Beautiful's
all the costumes prop material makeup so
there's a ton of stuff to do this is
going to be probably the biggest reviews
we've ever done today I'm working on
building the models for the two at least
two of the main vehicles and if I have
to have built some more but the two main
ones are the important ones Doug gave me
a sketch to go off
as you can see there on the top is the
sketch that that Doug gave me for how he
wanted the vehicles to look but that's
basically what I have to go off of so so
there's a little bit of creative license
there there's a little room for leeway
but there is actually a specific look
that dog has a mind and so he's been
coming in and kind of take a look at
some of the items that I've accumulated
and what I plan to do and stuff like
that with it so I went to about six
different like resale shops thrift
stores Goodwill Salvation Army and just
gathered up all I could like leather
jackets masks weapons toy trucks and
cars and vehicles and stuff like that
that I can kind of cut them all up
collar them together and make some cool
road warrior looking vehicles and stuff
so that's it you know bulldozer fire
truck use this kids aircraft carrier
parts for a few different things
hopefully when it's all done it'll
actually look kind of cool I'm sure if I
can be talking again later but that's it
like we're going to just jump right into
it and I'll shoot some video as I'm
going along and yeah hope you enjoy
okay this bad boy is the Thunder Road
Runner this was that was this the first
one you built or yeah well I built this
one in the coyote kind of at the same
time when I was looking for parts of
cars and stuff like that to build I was
like yeah kind of limited I went to
Goodwill's and just got anything that I
thought I that I thought could work and
when I saw this one originally the
roadrunner car was going to be like a
long pickup or another truck but when I
saw this I just thought it looked it
landed itself kind of comically too with
the big back well this wasn't the yeah
but it did have a bigger back tire and I
just thought oh my god I heard it had
the blue color already on it and I
thought this would be the perfect
Roadrunner car so it's a little little
uh road or ahead there yeah that's
adding kind of it it gets getting longer
and longer yeah beautiful paint job it's
it's just funny cuz it's just such a
domestic vehicle yeah heavy interesting
thing you wouldn't know yeah this
thing's pretty heavy yeah that one's
actually made out of steel it's got a
steel body on it yeah these other ones
you know even though even the Jeep the
Jeep is pretty white must have been to
get a bug little thing or something for
me Cooper or something cuz this we have
taken your Mini Cooper into fire but
yeah this is like the wheels off of a
pickup truck and then I made the exhaust
pipes to kind of give the like the
feathered kind of back and yeah just
more pieces of plastic Oh piece of a
battleship and stuff like that a smaller
engine yeah I saw what was left of the
battleship me yeah I remember asking
somebody hell did that guy was like on
the rotor and I'm like yeah like little
piece here will be there but yeah this
was like this piece is actually the
front of a of a toy gun that I cut off
and had laying around nice and then I
cut this piece to kind of look like the
the roadrunner
and then Doug was like I kind of want it
longer so then the day we filmed this
model I mocked up this little piece here
it's just out of wooden plumbers epoxy
nice and yeah it gives that really kind
of cool front spike kind of look and
yeah still has that silhouette sort of
of the roadrunner but yeah came together
pretty good
good job MacGyver I thank you ah
all right so swim went through a couple
names I originally was calling it the
coyote ugly but then since it's supposed
to be basically the coyote from the
Warner Brothers cartoons I decide to
call it the wild
rig coyote you get yeah whatever anyway
uh but for some reason says talk on the
side um hope they don't notice that but
yeah so this was the first model you
built Jim yeah pretty much type I kind
of built this one in the roadrunner at
the same time um this this one was the
showstopper Doe of the early models yeah
yeah he's been like that when it was
done I was like yeah this one looks like
you know oh well you know awesome yeah
walk into like George Miller's office or
something is my concept for you know
George Miller's Looney with me road ride
Bugs Bunny movie this guy loved this one
yeah so the business this is a truck I
drove playing a impractical Joe so I
like to think that these are seats by
the way and they just launched here oh
yeah yeah yeah so I get a very specific
kind of request as far as he had a look
like the roadrunner and coyote or
whatever so he's like it the arms have
to reach out somehow see the funny thing
is I would have seen I guess these are
the years but I would have thought maybe
these with years yeah well but it works
either way but yeah we would have to
take hands down initially I just have
these and then the day
stands like it needs something else some
pipes and I had mocked up some pipes dug
very good at their last minute but it
was fine was I kind of had these already
made up I just didn't know how to attach
them and then he was like yeah it looks
like somebody got a fury road now the so
what is all in this yeah this is the
body of is a-- is a fire truck like
there's a toy fire truck toy fire truck
oh no oh yeah and then the like this I
think is off yeah this is alpha like a
Tonka like bulldozer nice and a lot of
the smaller pieces is death or awful
battleship this is the front of a
battleship just turned upside down
oh wait wait oh so it's the front part
of the battleship yeah I just yeah I
just flipped it you have to imagine when
I showed up during when we were doing
some of the model work there was just
like these pieces of a battle it's like
when we're too happy right there own a
studio me and then I get the skulls
another crown last man that was like I
think it needs our nose you know it has
the kind but so that just was no brainer
it was just a nice touch because it's
very mad max but yeah this oh my god
love it is that from a monster truck I
need to cut off wheels yeah and then kid
told us quite a coyote maybe grew a bit
of a calculus yeah yeah I don't know
with the antenna yes and then yeah he's
come forward yeah when we shot the claws
coming down
it technically doesn't make any sense
because when these are on you can't go
in hit him so you notice like point we
should a community here and then you cut
to me going wow I'm you see it come down
it's very it's very t-rex he's tiny
little hands and you know we've been
hilarious if he keeps trying to whip his
hands back up and keeps getting stuck
just oh oh oh well we took a detour but
alright yeah so that is the wild rig
coyote
good job MacGyver again all right so
this bad boy here is uh where we calling
it
mother of all the mother of all noise I
said man cuz strangely enough
if she's hard to see there we go yeah
just as man on the front we found that
really amusing you know a it says man
but I think that's like a little coyote
or something underneath it what the yeah
yeah and so anyway uh this was the last
model we did we just did it today this
is like the final day of shooting and uh
yeah we needed somewhere for that so
it's like oh well we can use that for
the truck that Rob Scallon you know is
playing on so yeah basically did this it
was a very bright obnoxious blue and
black up front the interesting thing
about it is it had all of these decals
along the side running along here and
here and along basically the line here
so I basically ripped those off and what
was left was kind of the white pasty
stuff left on there still and it
actually when we spray-painted it left
these awesome texture marks which was
awesome so I know we covered the whole
thing in kind of black and then
spray-painting a little blue there and
some rust over here and Jim made these
speakers yes very cool the Front's of a
couple of old hair dryers which I just
have an abundance of yeah yeah and then
the inside is just some foam with the
tech in the center beautiful speakers so
yeah the man the mother of all noise
alright so this gorgeous piece of work
is Satan's little chubby it's a devil
Boehner's Jeep Jim you want to talk a
little bit about what we did here yeah
sure so um unlike the other two the
roadrunner in the coyote vehicles which
were an amalgam of various parts of
different vehicles and
all kind of thrown together this was a
jeep that I just had lying around and I
was gonna use four parts and didn't toy
chief from Goodwill right yeah yeah very
yellow and I looked at all the vehicles
most of the vehicles anyway were just
goodwill broken toys like cars and
trucks and stuff like that and yeah Doug
decided once we be on filming that he
wanted to do all the models and actual
model since he was going to use some CG
and stuff like that but the only kind of
CG is Michael Bay's yeah as it should be
so this one we we threw together in
about a half hour yeah this was the best
one and I said we threw it together this
is uh you can see the original Jeep sort
of chassis here and then we tagged on
all these things the foam up top it was
an open area half a year yeah yeah
tagged them what I love most of all is
this other half of a car yeah there's
the pickup run hard yeah this is like
the camp and the pickup in the back yeah
attach it to that and then we attach
this sort of motor piece here and then
actually originally attached to the
roadrunner car but it was so it was too
big and too ridiculous that I had to
take it off and put a small inline well
it had a second life and this lovely
grill up front which is only just foam
yeah and then was this part of the Jeep
it was our the GP okay so that came with
our mandate no no no those were not yeah
foam so yeah and then I ended up doing
the paint job we already had the base
yellow so just a lot of spray painting
with a Browns various gold so
interesting thing the dots here I had to
put on because when I did the hood for
the large mock-up of the Jeep to set the
spray cam broke and we had all these
large yellow dots so I make so I
had to paint all these little yellow
dots on kamancheh yeah even show off
yeah you may not yeah they may not even
show up on the shop but better safe than
sorry yeah salmon painted all the blood
in the Senedd and diana where the flames
always there was no I added I added the
anja area so yeah this is probably one
of my favorites that we did and it was
like the fastest one of the families
thrown together so yeah saying the
little chubby devil bonus cheats giving
me a watch over yeah okay so this came
from that this is all part of one toy
sad it was some tow truck type thing and
uh yeah this this was probably the
fastest yeah one we did really no
macgyvering necessary we just took this
very red car and yeah I probably had the
most fun in this just because all of
these mud splotches showed up the best
against the red and I mean it's not
because I got to paint boobs on the side
but uh yeah we were discussing with Doug
do we want anything on the side and bros
before hoes and we were coughing around
some ideas and looks like yeah I go with
that
so yeah just some sand does the mud I
Drive interview yeah that's that's the
car that he tried in the review but yeah
it's a lot of fun so pretty simple so
yeah this is the he van different from
the she rod so we tried to name all
these cars and retrigger that was the
best but he's gonna deer test out that
mount of fit woman again what I
could see the string Oh
okay the last of the vehicles this is
the sheer old shame road so one of the
easy pretty much we did yeah painted I
pretty much just bought this at Toys R
Us there was a mark control car and yeah
we ironically it was white and Doug
wanted something lighter color but it
was too glossy so we end up having to
put a black coat of spray paint on and
then like grating
yeah like couple coats of gray and then
just sprayed the whole thing with kind
of mud and dust and then we written the
equitable oh yeah so we had the I'm hard
for Hardy bumper sticker so I had to
paint that little thing on there just to
imply that and that Doug you've still
had it I still have it on the car yes
several men have been making kissy faces
yeah Jim had to drive to pick up some
spray paint in his dodgy car
alright well that's about it thank you
guys so much I hope you guys enjoyed
this series this was probably the NC
that I am the most proud of and had the
most fun working on because of the
variety of stuff that we had to do and
the amount of things was one of the
huger productions maybe the biggest one
that we've ever done once again thanks
to Rob for all the behind the scenes
stuff that he shot on the day of and for
all of his help during the building
process and helping me out with all the
props and stuff like that so yeah thanks
again guys for watching and we'll see
you next week